- Reminded everybody in
Ottawa yesterday or not Ottawa,
Ontario, excuse me, that
I didn't say shit for the
first 13 years of my career.
I just built a business.
No talking, just doing.
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, I've been telling you.
Today's episode, two things.
One, the lesson I taught Jordan,
which is consistency.
Putting in the work.
He's my trainer,
he taught me
how to get muscles,
how to get tone,
how to get focused.
And I taught him how
to be good at Instagram.
Saturday morning,
that's a weird profile.
Oh sorry.
That's a weird profile.
Jordan, (bell dings),
my trainer.
Jordan, when did we get focused
on Instagram more seriously?
- Right at the
beginning of the new year.
- And what has happened,
what'd I'd tell you to do and
what were you doing before?
- Before I was
posting once a day.
- [Gary] Mhmmm.
- Maybe.
- [Gary] If that.
- If that, honestly, not that.
Five times a week.
And then you said post
every day three times a day.
- Hashtags.
- Wait, wait?
- Hashtags, hashtags, you
showed me how to use hashtags.
- Three times a day.
- Engage.
- Engage with everyone, yep.
- Yep.
- First day I didn't do it.
First day, I did
two instead of three.
- I went crazy.
- You said, "I'm disappointed
in you." (laughs)
- I role reversed.
- And then from
that day, every day,
three times a day hashtags,
interacting and in less than
eight weeks I have
over 3,000 new followers.
- And the key is
not even the followers,
what I've been
most impressed with,
took a quick peek is
just the engagement level.
The way they care about you like
just you've built a community.
Forget about the
top line amounts.
Some people have
10,000 more followers
but only 187 care about them.
Of your 3,000 new followers it
feels like 2,000 care about you.
- Yeah. No, it's amazing.
Thank you
everyone that follows me.
- You're welcome.
Lesson number two,
it's very simple, my friends.
This a big one for me, one of
things that I'm spending a lot
of time on, one that a lot
of people aren't capable of
executing which is how much
better life is when you're the
bigger man and
woman in every situation.
No matter if
you're right or wrong,
no matter what it is, are you
capable of swallowing your pride
and having humility
to say you're sorry
even when maybe it
wasn't yours to
say you're sorry.
Leadership and
happiness really, really,
really comes at the ability to
focus on one move which is
can we be the bigger person?
The number one thing that
keeps good leaders from becoming
great, you know, to
be great at something
you have to over-index.
You just have to.
You have to be
able to be great at it.
You can be a good
basketball player,
you can be a
great basketball player,
and a lot of that
has to do with DNA,
so I think a lot of
natural leadership skills.
For me, the reason
I aspire to be a great leader is
I truly focused
on one variable,
and I want
everybody to hear this,
and it's a very sneaky
pillar of my life success,
which is, when
I think about you, India,
or you DRock, or anybody
that I jam with in my world,
startups, companies,
when I go to Oklahoma City,
the client, I'm trying
to provide 51% of the value.
I really believe that,
and not because
I'm this great human being,
'cause I think it's leverage.
I think that if DRock feels
that I'm slightly providing more
value to him than
he's providing to me,
financially,
upside in the future,
mentorship, whatever it may be,
that that's going to
make me a great leader.
A, it's how he feels about me,
and B, it's going to
focus me on always trying
to one-up the next person,
and when you're a leader,
one-upping comes in many forms.
I'm gonna continue to show you
angles that you haven't seen
about yourself, right?
I'm going to
continue to challenge you,
financially compensate you,
give you opportunities,
bring you to things.
One-upping, trying to provide
more value to the other person.
And I think a lot of
good leaders are
80-20 for themselves.
I think extremely
good leaders are 50-50.
I think great leaders start
to go to the 51-49 direction.
So much of my happiness and
success in relationships and
life are predicated
on that singular move.
Which is always
take on responsibility.
It's always your fault.
And it's become a theme in
the last couple of months in
relationships,
in friendships, in business,
for a lot of my friends
and contemporaries and I just
really want to do this rant.
It's a short Saturday
episode on that singular move.
It is big.
And so, little
homework for everybody.
If you're in the middle
of something right now,
try to be the bigger person.
Try to swallow your pride.
Try to erase the line
in the sand that you drew.
See what it feels like.
Try it, try to be
the bigger person.
(light music)